This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us form quick impressions of the strangers we meet. We do this automatically and unconsciously, and we do this all the time. We categorize people into nice and not so nice, friendly and unhelpful. Much of the time, these quick conclusions are partly true and partly exaggerated. They are caricatures of people we barely know. Our tendency to draw quick conclusions is especially powerful when the
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都会对遇到的陌生人迅速留下第一印象。我们自动且无意识地这样做，而且无时无刻不在这样做。我们会把人归为讨人喜欢和不太讨人喜欢、友好和帮不上忙的类别。很多时候，这些快速得出的结论部分是真实的，部分是被夸大了的。它们是我们几乎不了解的人的漫画式夸张。我们倾向于快速得出结论，尤其是当
strangers we encounter do something to hurt us. Think about the last time someone stepped on your foot as you were leaving a crowded theatre or the time a motorist nearly hit you as you were crossing a pedestrian intersection or when someone stole something from you. At such times, we can't help but imagine how terrible this person must be when they are not stepping on our toes or being a reckless driver or being a thief. Today on the program an unusual story about two strangers who first met as adversaries.
我们遇到的陌生人做出伤害我们的事情时。想想上一次你从拥挤的剧院离开时有人踩了你的脚，或者横过人行横道时一个驾车者差点撞到你，或者有人偷了你的东西。在那种时候，我们忍不住去想象，当这个人不是在踩我们的脚、不是在当马路杀手或者不是在当小偷时，他本人一定有多糟糕。今天的节目将讲述一个不同寻常的故事，关于两个最初作为对手相遇的陌生人。
Like all of us they came to quick conclusions about each other. But then nearly a decade later, each man had the opportunity to pull the curtain back on the other's life. How the simple act of conversation can transform the way we see each other. This week, on Hidden brain. James Carter still remembers the bike. It was a Trek 7.3 FX in blue, with Fender's a tow hitch and a bike bump and a waterbump holder. It was a great bike. It had all the gears of a standard racing bike, plus tires thick enough to withstand glass and gravel on city streets.
像我们所有人一样，他们对彼此迅速得出了结论。但随后在近十年后，其中一个人有机会拉开对方生活的帷幕。简单的对话如何能改变我们看待彼此的方式。本周，锁定《隐藏的大脑》。詹姆斯·卡特仍然记得那辆自行车。那是一辆蓝色的 Trek 7.3 FX，带有挡泥板、拖车钩、自行车打气筒和水壶架。这是一辆极好的自行车。它拥有标准赛车的所有齿轮，其轮胎厚度足以经受住城市街道上的玻璃和沙砾。
James loved his bike. It was his primary form of transportation after he immigrated to the United States from England. Definitely when I first moved over here that once my car license expired after the short period that it's valid internationally, I just rode a bike and took the bus to work. And so a lot of the time, if my wife was using the car then I would have to use the bicycle to get around with the kids. James lived in Harrisonburg, Virginia about two and a half hours southwest of Washington, DC. He chose the city because it was affordable, had good public schools, and low crime. When his two children were small, James ran errands with them with a trailer attached to his bike.
詹姆斯深爱他的自行车。自从他从英国移民到美国后，这是他的主要交通工具。绝对是的，我刚搬到这里时，我的汽车驾照在国际有效的一小段时间过期后，我基本上就是骑自行车和坐公交车去上班。所以很多时候，如果我妻子要用汽车，那我就必须骑自行车带着孩子到处跑。詹姆斯住在弗吉尼亚州的哈里森堡，位于华盛顿特区西南方向大约两个半小时车程的地方。他选择这座城市是因为这里生活成本可承受、公立学校好、犯罪率低。当他的两个孩子还小的时候，詹姆斯用自行车后面挂着的拖车带着他们跑腿。
James ran errands with them with a trailer attached to his bike. At the time I was the sole breadwinner in the house and so you have a bike in a trailer because that's really what you can afford to do on a daily basis versus paying for gasoline instead of food. James hadn't gone to college and he discovered it was hard to get a well-paying job. He found a gig maintaining and running websites at a local school. James Madison University. And at the time my wife didn't have a job so we were living below the poverty line for several years when we first moved to the United States.
詹姆斯用自行车后面挂着的拖车带着他们跑腿。当时我是家里唯一的经济支柱，所以你备有一辆自行车和一个拖车，因为相比于把钱花在汽油而不是食物上，这才是你日常能够负担得起的出行方式。詹姆斯没有上过大学，他发现很难找到一份薪水不错的工作。他在当地的一所学校——詹姆斯·麦迪逊大学找到了一份维护和运营网站的零工。当时我妻子没有工作刚搬到美国的前几年，我们一直是靠在贫困线以下。
Many of James' happier stories revolve around bikes. I think probably the fondest memory is when my youngest child, Eleanor, started to ride a bicycle without what we call stabilizers. I don't know what they're called in America. Training wheels. But the training wheels, yeah. Okay, so when Eleanor had the training wheels taken off of a bicycle and we were riding around the top level of the parking deck and I have a video of her just saying
詹姆斯的许多快乐记忆都围绕着自行车展开。我想最美好的记忆大概是我的小女儿埃莉诺开始学习骑没有我们称之为稳定器的自行车。我不知道在美国这叫什么。辅助轮。对，就是辅助轮。好吧，当埃莉诺的自行车的辅助轮被拆掉，我们在停车场顶层骑车时，我有一段视频记录了她一直在说
and that's what she just kept on saying over and over again as she would ride around this empty parking deck. James sometimes left his bike at work so he could get around campus. But one day, when he stepped outside his building, he couldn't find the bike. I looked down to check my bike, the bike rack, and noticed that it was gone. And I had a kryptonite lock. I've always been very, very careful about locking at my bike and making sure that you know, usually trying to put it through the wheel as well as the frame. When you saw the bike missing what went through your mind James? It was probably a feeling of panic that just dread that dropped into my heart straight away to see that part of my life just gone. And there's all sorts of emotions of concern,
这就是她骑着车绕着这个空荡荡的停车场转圈时一遍又一遍重复的话。詹姆斯有时会把自行车留在单位，这样他就可以在校园里代步。但有一天，当他走出大楼时，却找不到那辆自行车了。我低头检查我的自行车、自行车架，发现它不见了。我有一把氪金锁。我一直非常非常小心地锁好自行车，确保通常会把锁穿过车轮以及车架。詹姆斯，当你发现自行车不见了，你脑子里在想什么？那可能是一种恐慌的感觉，一种恐惧瞬间沉入我的心底，看到我生活的一部分就这样消失了。各种各样的情绪涌现出来，比如担忧、
of anger, of hurt. When you go through that, of why is this person doing this to me? For some people, having a bike stolen is an annoyance, a headache. For James, it was a disaster. He needed his bike for work and to take care of his family. How was he going to get to appointments around campus, run errands on the weekend? He reported the theft to campus police. And it kind of felt like they were just filling out some paperwork so that I could complete an insurance claim, which I knew there was no way that I would be able to purchase a new bike with the deductible
愤怒、受伤。当你经历这一切时，你会想，这个人为什么要对我做这种事？对有些人来说，自行车被偷只是一件烦心事、令人头疼。对詹姆斯来说，这是一场灾难。他上班需要自行车，照顾家庭也需要自行车。他怎么去校园各处开会，怎么在周末跑腿？他向校园警察报了案。感觉他们就像是在填写一些纸质文件，好让我去办保险索赔，而我知道我的房屋保险免赔额
on my home insurance. And it was really disappointing because I knew there was no way I was going to be able to afford a new bike or replace it in any way, shape or form. James was anguished. He was scraping by and the thief had taken one of the few things that held his life together. When he got home he flipped open his laptop and decided to put his internet skills to use. I started googling how to get your stolen bike back and I came across a website that had various different tips on there
让我根本不可能买得起一辆新自行车。这真的很令人失望，因为我知道我无论如何也买不起新自行车，也没有任何办法去替换它。詹姆斯痛苦万分。他本就勉强度日，而小偷却拿走了维持他生活的为数不多的物件之一。回到家后，他翻开笔记本电脑，决定发挥他的互联网技能。我开始在谷歌上搜索如何找回被偷的自行车，然后我偶然看到一个网站，上面有各种各样的提示
about the steps that I needed to take to try and get my bike back. And that was reporting it to the National Stolen Bike Registry, local bike shops, local used goods shops. And one of those was setting up alerts for Craig's list in the state that you're in and the surrounding states as well. The idea was to spot the thief if he posted an ad to sell the bike. So I set up a series of Google alerts for every Craigslist in Virginia, North Carolina, West Virginia, Maryland and DC. And Trek was the keyword that I searched for. Now, did I believe that I was going to get it back? I wasn't that hopeful. But several days later, one alert did go off. I received an email that said Trek 7.3 FX Blue Harrisonburg, Virginia. I thought no, surely can't be the case.
关于我需要采取哪些步骤来试图找回我的自行车。其中包括向国家失窃自行车登记处、当地自行车店、当地二手商品店报案。其中之一就是在你所在的州以及周边州设置 Craigs list（克雷格列表）的警报。这个想法是，如果小偷发布出售自行车的广告，就能发现他。所以我为弗吉尼亚州、北卡罗来纳州、西弗吉尼亚州、马里兰州和华盛顿特区的所有 Craigslist 设置了一系列谷歌警报。Trek 是我搜索的关键词。当时我相信我能把它找回吗？我并没有抱太大希望。但几天后，一个警报真的响了。我收到一封电子邮件，上面写着：Trek 7.3 FX 蓝色，弗吉尼亚州哈里森堡。我想，不会吧，绝对不可能是这辆。
And I clicked on the link and there was my bike. It had the trailer hitch attached to the saddle, it had all of the accessories that I'd put on the bike, it was my bike without a shadow of a doubt. I'd put on the bike, it was my bike without a shadow of a doubt. James reason that he could not respond to the Craigslist ad and accuse the seller of stealing his bike. Surely, the thief would simply vanish. And so, I decided to set up a bunch of fakie melodresses and each email address had a persona attached to it because I knew that if this guy sold the bike I'd never see it again. So I had created
我点击了链接，我的自行车就在那里。车座上挂着拖车钩，上面有我加装的所有配件，毫无疑问，这就是我的自行车。我加装的自行车，毫无疑问就是我的自行车。詹姆斯心想，他不能直接回复 Craigslist 的广告并指责卖家偷了他的自行车。毫无疑问，小偷会直接消失。所以，我决定注册一堆虚假的电子邮箱地址，每个邮箱地址背后都有一个对应的人设，因为我知道如果这家伙把车卖了，我就再也见不到它了。所以我创建了
people and if I remember correctly it was like a housewife who was trying to get her husband to start getting back into exercising, someone who wanted to upgrade their bike, those sorts of things. And so I created various different emails with Yahoo and Google and some other platforms. So it didn't seem obviously that it was all coming from the same person. So let me just understand what you're saying. You're saying that because other people might have been trying to buy that bike as well, you in some ways wanted to flood the market with offers
各种身份。如果我没记错的话，比如一个试图说服丈夫开始重新锻炼的家庭主妇，一个想要升级自行车的人，诸如此类的人设。于是我用雅虎、谷歌和其他一些平台创建了各种不同的电子邮件。这样看起来就不会明显是同一个人发出的。所以让我理清一下你的意思。你是说，因为其他人可能也想买那辆自行车，所以在某种程度上，你想用大量的报价来充斥市场，
that were all coming from you. So that if he picked one person to sell the bike to, odds were that person would be you. Correct. And I had a couple that I knew I was going to try and drop the price down and was offering low numbers. And then others that I was offering more favorable pricing on. And ultimately we whittled down to just this one individual that he then agreed to meet to sell the bike to.
而这些报价全部来自于你。这样如果他挑一个人把自行车卖掉，那个人很有可能是你的概率就会很大。没错。我知道有几个人我会试着把价格压低，出价很低。还有一些人我会给出更优惠的价格。最终，我们缩小范围，只剩下了这一个家伙，然后他同意和我见面把自行车卖给我。
James arranged to meet the seller, a man who called himself Donovan at a Starbucks. Then he made a phone call. I phoned up the Harrisonburg Police Department and essentially told them that I've managed to find a criminal who's stolen my bicycle and he's going to meet up with me to sell it back to me. And so it was, it was phrased more in a sense of, hey, my bike was stolen. I've managed to find it on Craigslist and I'm meeting the guy at Starbucks at a certain time today. Would you like to be a part of that to tell me get the bike back?
詹姆斯安排与卖家见面，那是一个自称唐纳文的男子，地点在星巴克。然后他打了一个电话。我打电话给哈里森堡警察局，基本上告诉他们我设法找到了偷我自行车的罪犯，他要和我见面把车卖给我。所以当时的情况是，措辞更偏向于：嘿，我的自行车被偷了。我设法在 Craigslist 上找到了它，今天某个时间我要在星巴克和这家伙见面。你们想不想参与进来，帮我把自行车找回来？
And they were thrilled and just needed to find an unmarked police car to come to the location. When James got to the Starbucks ahead of the meeting, he was nervous. So I was sat inside of the Starbucks waiting for him to arrive. I'd been emailing back and forth from that location. And I saw him arrive in his car with two bikes on the back of it, one of which was mine. And so I called the police to let them know that he'd arrived. And they said that they were still trying to find a unmarked car but would try and be there as soon as possible. James pondered whether he could go through with a sting on his own without the police.
他们非常兴奋，只需要找一辆便衣警车去那个地点就行了。当詹姆斯在会面之前到达星巴克时，他很紧张。所以我坐在星巴克里面等他到达。我一直在那个地方发邮件。我看到他开车到了，车后面带着两辆自行车，其中一辆是我的。所以我打电话给警察，让他们知道他已经到了。他们说他们仍在努力寻找便衣车，但会尽最大努力尽快赶到。詹姆斯琢磨着是否可以不等警察，自己一个人去设局。
He waited a bit, then called the police again. And I relayed to them that he said he was only going to stay around for a short period of time. He had other people interested in it and I knew that, you know, And I relayed to them that he said he was only going to stay around for a short period of time. He had other people interested in it. And I knew that this was my one and only chance to get the bike. It was like a scene from a movie. James Wade is options. I was considering whether I just run outside and grab the bike and go.
他等了一会儿，又给警察打了电话。我向他们转达说，他说自己只会待很短的时间。还有其他人对它感兴趣，我知道，你知道的，我向他们转达说，他说自己只会待很短的时间。还有其他人对它感兴趣。我知道这是我拿回自行车的唯一机会。这就像电影里的场景。詹姆斯权衡着他的选择。我在考虑我是不是该直接跑出去抓起自行车就走。
And all sorts of things are going through my head. I grew up in the UK. You don't have to worry about guns and knives, really, to the degree that you do in the United States. So everything that I do over here that could potentially involve a confrontation, that is my immediate thought. The driver of the car with the stolen bikes got out.
各种各样的念头在我脑海里闪过。我在英国长大。在美国，你真的不需要像在这里那样担心枪支和刀具。所以在这里，任何可能涉及对峙的事情，都是我立刻想到的。开着载有失窃自行车汽车的司机下了车。
He walked toward the Starbucks. James got a good look at him. He didn't look like a gangster. He looked like a student. He didn't look threatening. He... Not what I was expecting. He was driving a clean and a nice car.
他朝星巴克走去。詹姆斯看清了他的长相。他看起来不像个歹徒。他看起来像个学生。他看起来不具威胁性。他……跟我想象的不一样。他开着一辆干净漂亮的汽车。
He had a nice bike rack on the back of it. And I don't know what I was expecting to arrive, but I remember thinking that, okay, this person looks like they're probably reasonably well off, they were well presented, that kind of thing. Seeing the well dressed thief and his nice car made James very angry. When you know the potential hardship
车后面挂着一个漂亮的自行车架。我不知道我期待着一个什么样的人出现，但我记得当时想的是，好吧，这个人看起来可能相当富裕，衣着光鲜，诸如此类。看到衣着光鲜的小偷和他的好车，詹姆斯非常生气。当你了解潜在的苦难
that you're gonna have to go through and someone else is stealing your property and it doesn't appear like there is a real need. If someone came to me and say, I stole your bike because I don't have enough money to feed my kids, that's a very different story to someone who has their own vehicle and looks well presented. So certainly, yes, there was immense disappointment.
当你将要经历这些，而别人却在偷你的财产，并且看起来并没有什么真正的需求时。如果有人来找我说，我偷你的自行车是因为我没有足够的钱养活孩子，这和那些自己有车且衣着光鲜的人完全是两码事。所以当然，是的，有巨大的失望。
Meanwhile, the cops still had not arrived. James Cooley let Donovan get to the Starbucks counter and order a drink. He didn't identify himself. But thankfully, shortly after my phone rang, and it was the police to say that they were outside in an unmarked car and they needed me to come outside and identify myself. So I walked outside and raised my hand in the air and ran it through my hair and they confirmed that they've seen me and then told me that I needed to engage the suspect in a transaction. And so I walked back into Starbucks and looked around as if I'm trying to see someone and
与此同时，警察还是没有到。詹姆斯眼看着唐纳文走到星巴克柜台点了一杯饮料。他没有表露身份。但谢天谢地，不久后我的手机响了，是警察打来的，说他们在外面的一辆便衣车里，需要我出去表明身份。所以我走出去，把手举在空中，用手抓了抓头发，他们确认看到我了，然后告诉我需要去和嫌疑人进行交易。所以我走回星巴克，环顾四周，好像在找人一样，
deliberately don't look at him, walk out to the car, look at the bike, and I literally just press the tyre on my bike to try and see what the air pressure is like. And with that, he walks out and comes over to me and asks me if I'm the person that he's been communicating with viam. And with that, I shake his hand. And this red unmarked police car comes flying into the parking lot. And two police officers get out of the vehicle. They tackle the young man and throw him to the ground. They told James to go back in the coffee shop. And so I walked back in and the barista asks me what's going on outside. And I said, well, that guy out there is getting arrested for stealing my bicycle. And so the barista then looks at me and says, hey, everyone, and picks up Don's Frappuccino and says, Don's going downtown
故意不看他，走到车旁，看了一眼自行车，我 буквально (字面意思) 按了按我自行车的轮胎，想看看气压怎么样。就在这时，他走出来朝我走过来，问我是不是那个一直在通过私信与他联系的人。随着这句话，我跟他握了握手。这辆红色的便衣警车呼啸着冲进停车场。两名警察从车里下来。他们把这个年轻男子扑倒在地，摔在地上。他们让詹姆斯回到咖啡店里。所以我走了进去，咖啡师问我外面发生什么事了。我说，哦，外面那家伙因为偷我的自行车被捕了。然后咖啡师看着我，大声说，嘿，大家听着，拿起唐的星冰乐说，唐要去局子里吃牢饭了，
for stealing a bike. Would you like his Frappuccino? And so I take the Frappuccino, sit down while I watched Don being arrested for stealing my bicycle. And it was quite possibly the most perfect moment that I've ever had in my entire life of having this amazing cold Frappuccino being given to me because the person that bought it it was going to be thrown away and that person was getting arrested for stealing my bike. And so there was this kind of great moment of justice happening right here. I was reunited with my bike
因为他偷了一辆自行车。你想喝他的星冰乐吗？所以我拿了星冰乐，坐下来看着唐因为偷我的自行车而被捕。这很可能是我一生中经历过的最完美的时刻，有人把这杯神奇的冰镇星冰乐送给我，因为买它的人要被扔掉了，而那个人因为偷我的自行车而被捕。所以这里有一种正义得到伸张的绝妙时刻。我和我的自行车团聚了，
and the police also found bolt cutters in the back of his car with my bike lock and helmet in there. And he was taken away to be processed whatever they did with him. Justice had been served with whipped cream on top. Or had it? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Donovan grew up in Florida and Virginia, the oldest child in a middle-class family.
警察还在他车的后备箱里找到了断线钳，里面有我的自行车锁和头盔。他被带走去处理了，无论他们对他的程序是什么。正义得到了伸张，上面还加了奶油。真的是这样吗？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。唐纳文在佛罗里达州和弗吉尼亚州长大，是一个中产阶级家庭的长子。
We're going to use only his first name in this story for reasons that will become clear shortly. His dad was from Singapore, his mom from Pennsylvania. But yeah, they were pretty strict. They had a lot of intentions of me, you know, excelling academically. Lots of, I did feel like there was a lot of pressure growing up to become a physician or a physician assistant or something like that. Donovan attended James Madison University
出于很快就会明的原因，我们在本故事中只使用他的名字。他的父亲来自新加坡，母亲来自宾夕法尼亚州。但是，是的，他们非常严格。他们对我有很多期望，你知道的，要在学术上取得优异成绩。有很多，我确实觉得在成长过程中有很多压力，要成为一名医生或医师助理之类的。唐纳文就读于詹姆斯·麦迪逊大学，
in Harrisonburg, Virginia. He hoped to go to medical school. But he struggled in some of his pre-med classes and had to shift gears. He graduated with a degree in health sciences. So this was about a year after I graduated from college. I was working at a hospital as a cardiac tech. Working long shifts, probably 12 hour shifts,
位于弗吉尼亚州哈里森堡。他希望去医学院上学。但他在一些预科课程中苦苦挣扎，不得不转变方向。他获得了健康科学学位毕业。所以这大约是我大学毕业一年后。我在一家医院担任心脏技术员。工作时间很长，可能是12小时的班，
three to five days a week depending on the shift. Trying to save up a lot of money to become a medical technologist with the hospital that I was currently working at. So they had this great program where you could work and earn your master's degree at this accredited program and then I was accepted. Donovan was worried about the cost of grad school. He wasn't sure he could afford it
一周工作三到五天，取决于班次。努力存一大笔钱，以便在我当时工作的医院成为一名医学技术专家。所以他们有一个很棒的项目，你可以在那里工作并在这个获得认证的项目中获得硕士学位，然后我被录取了。唐纳文担心研究生院的费用。他不确定自己是否负担得起，
since he'd have to cut back his work hours while attending school. When he totaled up the tuition payments and subtracted the income he would be losing, the numbers didn't add up. But then, he had a light bulb moment. I had done the calculation for the rent that I was owing at the place that I was renting, and I realized that it would be more advantageous to just buy a house actually find some tenants get some money from the tenant income.
因为他在上学期间必须减少工作时间。当他把学费加起来并减去将要失去的收入时，数字对不上了。但随后，他灵光一闪。我计算了我当时租的房子的房租，我意识到，实际上买一套房，找一些租客拿一些租金收入会更有利。
And that would be the supplement to the work that I would have lost while I did my education. It seemed like a perfect solution. He found a house to buy and had enough money for the down payment. Or rather, he had almost enough. He was about $400 short. He felt he couldn't ask his parents for money, or borrow it from friends. He needed to get his hands on some cash. Fast. I think it just popped him to my head. What is the easiest way to get $400 quickly. I had seen some bicycles on the side of the road that I thought I could take and fix them up
这将是对我在求学期间失去的工作收入的补充。这听觉像是一个完美的解决方案。他找到了一套要买的房子，并且有足够的钱支付首付。或者说，他有差不多足够的钱。他还差大约 400 美元。他觉得他不能向父母要钱，也不能向朋友借钱。他需要弄到一些现金。快点。我想这个念头一下子就蹦进我的脑子里了。怎么能最快弄到 400 美元。我看到路边有一些自行车，我想我可以把它们拿走并修理好，
and try to sell them on Craigslist. Because I was really big into biking through much of my college years, and I understood the inner workings of a bike and felt like my expertise in fixing bikes was adequate enough that I could make a profit off of this. Donovan was pretty sure the bikes had been sitting around for a while. So they were pretty nice hybrid bikes and they had just been sitting there for it was weeks
然后试着在 Craigslist 上卖掉它们。因为在大学的绝大部分时间里我都非常喜欢骑自行车，而且我了解自行车的内部运作，觉得我对修车足够的专业知识足以让我从中获利。唐纳文确信这些自行车已经停放了一段时间了。所以它们是非常不错的混合动力自行车，而且就那样放在那里有几个星期了，
and weeks. I mean, it might have even been months, but they looked abandoned. I think they had a rusty chain that could have been replaced. Donovan had never stolen a bike before, but he rationalized that if the bikes were abandoned, he would be committing a victimless crime. But that didn't stop him from being terrified at what he was about to do.
几个星期。我的意思是，甚至可能是几个月，但它们看起来像被遗弃了。我想它们有一条可以更换的生锈链子。唐纳文以前从未偷过自行车，但他合理化地认为，如果这些自行车是被遗弃的，他就是在犯一个没有受害者的罪行。但这并没有阻止他对即将要做的事感到恐惧。
I was absolutely afraid I was gonna get caught. I knew it was something bad to do, but I felt like I had no other choice. And this also would have been the quickest way to bring in $400. I bought a $20 set of chain cutters. And I went in the middle of the night you know observing that nobody else was around. I parked her real quickly, snipped the chains and then put them in the back of my car. I mean was your heart pounding through all of this? I mean what did it feel like to be doing this?
我绝对害怕自己会被抓。我知道这是一件不好的事，但我觉得我别无选择。这也是筹集 400 美元的最快方法。我买了一套 20 美元的链条剪。我在半夜去，观察到周围没有其他人。我很快把车停好，剪断链条，然后把它们放进我的车后备箱里。我的意思是，这一切过程中你的心脏一直在狂跳吗？做这种事是什么感觉？
I think this was probably one of the highest anxiety points that I've ever experienced was committing this crime. It felt really bad when I did it. Donovan drove the bikes back to his apartment. His place was on the second floor, so he carried the bikes up the stairs one by one. And I think I didn't even look at them the rest of the night because I just wanted to deal with it in the morning, what I had done. Shortly afterwards, his mind set on making the down payment, Donovan fixed up the bikes, snapped some photos, and posted an ad on Craigslist. And then I got a response almost immediately
我想这可能是我经历过的焦虑最高点之一，就是犯下这宗罪。当我做完的时候，感觉真的很糟糕。唐纳文把自行车开回了他的公寓。他的住处在二楼，所以他一辆接一辆地把自行车扛上楼梯。我想那天晚上我甚至都没看它们一眼，因为我只想在早上处理我所做过的事。不久之后，坚定了支付首付决心的唐纳文修好了自行车，拍了一些照片，并在 Craigslist 上发布了广告。然后我几乎立刻就得到了回应，
actually. I think it was like within a day. They said they were very interested in buying the bikes. That very interested buyer, of course, was James Carter. Donovan didn't do much to cover his tracks. He identified himself as Donovan to the persona that James set set up. When Donovan got to the Starbucks, he had to remind himself not to act like a criminal. I went into the Starbucks to grab a drink while I waited trying to act as normal and as level headed as possible. I'm doing normal things that a person would who's waiting for you know a normal transaction. And I remember I looked out the Starbucks window and I saw somebody looking at the bikes. So before I even was, my name was called at the Starbucks, I walked out the door.
实际上。我想大概不到一天。他们说他们对买自行车非常感兴趣。那个非常感兴趣的买家，当然就是詹姆斯·卡特。唐纳文并没有做太多来掩盖他的行踪。他在詹姆斯设立的人设面前自称是唐纳文。当唐纳文到达星巴克时，他必须提醒自己不要表现得像个罪犯。我走进星巴克买一杯饮料，同时等待，尽量表现得尽可能正常和冷静。我正在做正常人等待正常交易时会做的事情。我记得我向星巴克窗外望去，看到有人在看那些自行车。所以甚至在我被星巴克叫到名字之前，我就走出了门。
And immediately I found myself shoved down to the ground, put in handcuffs, and dragged over to the police car. And then I saw that there were about five or six police cars and another 10 to 12 police just standing around. One cop asked Donovan where he'd gotten the bikes. I told him I just bought them, fixed them up, and was playing and reselling them. So I immediately, my brain just went into defense mode and I started making up a story,
然后我立刻发现自己被推倒在地，戴上手铐，拖到了警车旁。然后我看到有大约五六辆警车和另外 10 到 12 名警察站在周围。一个警察问唐纳文他是从哪里弄到这些自行车的。我告诉他我刚买的，修好了，打算倒卖。所以我立刻，我的大脑进入了防卫模式，我开始编造一个故事，
trying to pretend to be innocent. And what went through your mind and your heart when you saw they were surrounded by police don't even? What goes through your mind at that point? I mean, must have been terrifying. Yeah, it was very terrifying. I think I knew that I had made a major mistake and that, you know, I think I was raised to always tell the truth.
试图假装自己是无辜的。唐纳文，当你看到周围都是警察时，你的脑海和心里在想什么？那一刻你心里在想什么？我的意思是，一定很吓人吧。是的，非常吓人。我想我知道自己犯了一个重大的错误，而且，你知道的，我想我从小受到的教育就是要说实话。
You know, tell the truth and it'll set me free naively. So I initially made up a story, but then I recounted on it. I do remember I did tell them I took the bikes after I waved my Miranda rights. And why did you do that? Did you just feel like it was pointless or what was happening? Yeah, I actually did feel like it was pointless at that point. Because I thought to myself, oh my goodness, there's so many police here, they must have,
你知道，说实话就会让我解脱，这很天真。所以我最初编造了一个故事，但我后来反悔了。我确实记得，在我放弃米兰达警告后，我确实告诉了他们我拿了自行车。你为什么要这么做？你只是觉得毫无意义还是发生了什么？是的，我当时确实觉得毫无意义。因为我心里想，哦天哪，这里有这么多警察，他们一定，
this is clearly a sting operation of some sort. Because how else would they know that these bikes are stolen? The police drove Donovan down to the station, snapped mug shots, booked and released him. His trial would come a few months later. But even before the trial, his life began to unravel. My mug shot had been posted on this website for local crimes and Someone at the hospital who knew me must have seen this mugshot and then reported that to my manager and my manager
这显然是某种钓鱼执法行动。因为他们怎么会知道这些自行车是被偷的呢？警察把唐纳文带到警察局，拍了面部照片，记录在案并释放了他。他的审判将在几个月后到来。但甚至在审判之前，他的生活就开始分崩离析了。我的面部照片被发布在当地犯罪的这个网站上，医院里认识我的人一定看到了这张面部照片，然后向我的经理报告了，我的经理
proceeded to send me an email claiming that you know we have been notified that you were involved in a crime. And you will be released from your work effective immediately. And I already had at my anxiety level been really high thinking that it was a really terrible crime. And to know that it was on in public display was even more traumatic, I think, in a lot of ways. public display was even more traumatic, I think, in a lot of ways.
接着给我发了一封电子邮件，声称你知道我们接到通知说你卷入了一起犯罪。你将被立即解雇。我的焦虑水平已经很高了，认为这是一起非常可怕的犯罪。而且知道它被公之于众，在很多方面甚至更具创伤性。公之于众，在很多方面甚至更具创伤性。
Soon afterwards, Donovan received another blow. He had been about to start his master's program, coming up with ways to pay the tuition, had been the driving force behind his desire to make a quick $400. Just a few days later, I got a second email from the school that was associated with the hospital stating that due to you being involved in a crime, we have decided to rescind our offer to your acceptance into our master's program.
不久之后，唐纳文又遭到了沉重打击。他本要开始他的硕士项目，寻找支付学费的方法曾是他想要快速赚取 400 美元的动力。就在几天后，我收到了来自与医院相关联的学校的第二封电子邮件，上面说由于你卷入了一起犯罪，我们决定撤回对你被录取进入硕士项目的录取通知。
And this is all again before I had even really been convicted. The most ironic part, after he was arrested, Donovan reviewed his finances. The crazy thing is that I, again, did a calculation and found that I had enough money for this down payment. So I ended up actually within the next couple weeks, I actually ended up buying the house that I was originally having the problem with. So that was the great irony of it all,
而且这一切再次发生在我甚至还没有真正被定罪之前。最具讽刺意味的是，在他被捕后，唐纳文检查了他的财务状况。疯狂的事情是，我再次进行了计算，发现我有足够的钱来支付这个首付。所以我实际上在接下来的几周内，真的买下了我最初遇到困难的那栋房子。所以这一切最大的讽刺是，
is that I actually did not need the money from these bicycles that I had stolen. As Donovan's trial approached, the prosecutor contacted James. And he told me that because of the value of the bicycles, which wasn't a huge amount, but it was going to be grand last night, which is a felony conviction. James was taken aback. He wanted Donovan held to account, but he didn't want him to have a felony felony conviction. James was taken aback.
我其实并不需要我偷来的这些自行车的钱。随着唐纳文的审判临近，检察官联系了詹姆斯。他告诉我，由于自行车的价值，虽然不是一笔巨额资金，但它将是一项重罪定罪。詹姆斯大吃一惊。他希望唐纳文承担责任，但他不希望他有重罪定罪。詹姆斯大吃一惊。
He wanted Donovan held to account, but he didn't want him to have a felony conviction that would dog him for the rest of his life. And so I spoke to him a bit about how in the UK we have the rehabilitation of offenders act, where if you commit a nonviolent crime after a certain time period, that is expunge from your record. No one can find it out unless you're applying as a spy or some sort of top-level government job, it's not going to impact your ability to get a regular job. And so for me, it's important that once someone serves their time, that that's it. They've done it.
他希望唐纳文承担责任，但又不想让他背上会纠缠他余生的重罪定罪记录。所以我跟他谈了一些关于英国如何实行《罪犯改过自新法案》的情况，如果你犯了非暴力罪行，经过一定时间后，该记录就会被消除。没有人能查到，除非你申请当间谍或某种高层政府工作，否则它不会影响你找到普通工作的能力。所以对我来说，重要的是，一旦一个人服刑完毕，那就是结束了。他们已经完成了。
They've served their time. They made a mistake and they've served the punishment. For that to continue after either a fine or an imprisonment or whatever it is that the judge passes down seems counterproductive. So, I wanted Donovan to be able to, once this was over and done with, get a job, pay taxes, and feed back into the system, be able to vote. All of those sorts of things that get taken away with a felony conviction. And so after a while, the prosecutor contacted me again, and if I remember correctly, they talked about how the sentence should have been 600 days, and what they were going to do
他们已经服刑了。他们犯了个错误，也受到了惩罚。如果这种惩罚在罚款、监禁或法官下达的任何判决之后继续下去，似乎会适得其反。所以，我希望唐纳文在这件事结束后，能够找到工作、纳税、重新回馈系统，并且能够投票。所有那些因重罪定罪而被剥夺的权力。所以在过了一段时间后，检察官再次联系了我，如果我没记错的话，他们谈到本应判处 600 天监禁，而他们打算做的是
was suspend it down to 30 days, and he would have to pay for the cost of his incarceration and it would be a misdemeanor. So what did you tell the prosecutor? Absolutely. Go ahead, no hesitation whatsoever. And what happened next? That was the last I heard of it. James's role in the legal process was over, but for Donovan, it was just beginning. He was convicted of petty larceny, paid a fine, and spent a month in jail. His conviction had been reduced from a felony to two misdemeanors, but that conviction was now a part of his criminal record.
将其缓刑减至 30 天，他必须支付监禁费用，并且这将是一项轻罪。那你对检察官说了什么？当然。去吧，毫无犹豫。接下来发生了什么？那是关于这件事我听到的最后消息了。詹姆斯在法律程序中的角色结束了，但对唐纳文来说，这只是一切的开始。他被判犯有小偷罪，缴纳了罚款，并在监狱里度过了一个月。他的定罪从重罪减为两项轻罪，但这项定罪现在已经成了他犯罪记录的一部分。
After his conviction, Donovan was able to rent out the rooms in his house, but he discovered that getting a job was not easy. So I started traveling around trying to look for little jobs. Ironically, you know, trying to apply to a Starbucks, trying to apply to a fitness, different fitness areas. I think I applied to probably 20 different places over the coming year. Donovan could practically write the script for his job interviews.
定罪后，唐纳文得以将房子里的房间出租，但他发现找工作并不容易。所以我开始到处寻找小工作。讽刺的是，你知道的，去星巴克应聘，去健身房，不同的健身领域应聘。我想我在接下来的一年里大概应聘了 20 个不同的地方。唐纳文几乎可以写出他的求职面试剧本。
No matter where he went, the conversation unfolded the same way. Everything on my resume looked great. I had really great references, but then I would be upfront went, the conversation unfolded the same way. We can't allow that. So immediately I would be denied. Donovan also realized that the conviction had consequences for his personal life. About a year after his release, his education plans timid, his employment prospects dim, Donovan went to visit his partner for the weekend. He was a park ranger at Shenandoah National Park. So I was driving on Skyline Boulevard, coming to visit him to stay for the weekend.
无论他去哪里，对话的发展都是一样的。我简历上的所有东西看起来都很棒。我有非常棒的推荐信，但随后我会坦白……对话的发展都是一样的。我们不能允许这样。所以我立刻就被拒绝了。唐纳文也意识到这次定罪对他的个人生活产生了影响。在他获释大约一年后，由于教育计划黯淡、就业前景黯淡，唐纳文去拜访他的伴侣过周末。他是谢andoah国家公园的一名公园巡警。所以我当时正开车在天际线上，去拜访他过周末。
And I had been going down one of the hills that are a little bit faster and wasn't paying attention. This was at 8 o'clock at night when nobody else is in the park. And I get pulled over. I did tell them that I was on probation. So then they asked me who I was visiting. I said, oh, I'm visiting so and so down at the employee housing. So they said, okay, we're going to call your probation officer.
我当时正开着车下一段稍微有点快的山坡，没有集中注意力。那是晚上 8 点，公园里没有其他人。我被拦了下来。我确实告诉过他们我在试用期。然后他们问我在拜访谁。我说，哦，我在拜访员工宿舍里的某某。所以他们说，好吧，我们要给你的缓刑官打电话。
And in my head, I'm thinking, okay, they're just going to call a probation officer. This is all going to get taken care of. Nothing's going to happen. And I'm just going to go on to finish my weekend. And before I know it, I see another park ranger vehicle coming my way and then my partner steps out of the park ranger vehicle and I'm thinking, oh my gosh, they just called him.
在我脑海里，我想，好吧，他们只是打个电话给缓刑官。这一切都会得到解决的。什么都不会发生。我只要去过完我的周末就行了。还没等我反应过来，我看到另一辆公园巡警车朝我开过来，然后我的伴侣从巡警车里走了出来，我想，哦天哪，他们刚刚给他打电话了。
So then he says, okay, I'm gonna drive your vehicle back to employee housing. And even then, I still did not tell him I was so ashamed of these charges. So anyways, we get back to the employee housing and he says, okay, let's go for a walk. And he says, dude, is there something that you need to tell me? I said, I said, no, there's nothing I need to tell you. So then he says, well, I know about your charges.
然后他说，好吧，我来把你的车开回员工宿舍。即便如此，我还是没有告诉他，我为这些指控感到太羞耻了。无论如何，我们回到员工宿舍，他说，好吧，我们去散步吧。然后他说，老兄，你有什么需要告诉我的吗？我说，我说，没有什么需要告诉你的。然后他说，好吧，我知道你的指控了。
And so then I broke down and explained to him, yes, I'm ashamed of these. This is something that happened a year and a half ago. I talked to him about that. How did that affect your relationship going forward? This affected it in a way that I think he felt like I was not telling him everything. I was not, I was being untruthful, which I was. It was an incredibly low point in my life. I would absolutely say that I thought of ending my life because this was total
于是我崩溃了，向他解释，是的，我为这些感到羞耻。这是一件发生在一个半月前的事。我跟他谈了那件事。这会对你们未来的关系产生什么影响？这产生的影响是，我想他觉得我没有把一切都告诉他。我没有，我在说谎，而我确实在说谎。这是我生命中极其低谷的时刻。我绝对会说我曾想过结束自己的生命，因为这是对我职业生涯发展愿景的彻底
destruction of my view of how my career was going to go. James Carter knew nothing of what happened to Donovan. Donovan knew next to nothing about James. The courts and prosecutors did their work and moved on. But as I learned the details of what had happened, I couldn't help wondering if this was an example of justice being served, who exactly had it served? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. For years after he recovered his stolen bike, James Carter remembered the incident as a moment of triumph.
摧毁。詹姆斯·卡特对唐纳文身上发生的事情一无所知。唐纳文对詹姆斯也几乎一无所知。法庭和检察官完成了他们的工作便继续前行。但当我了解到事情的细节时，我忍不住想这是否是一个伸张正义的例子，这究竟是对谁伸张了正义？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在他找回被偷的自行车多年后，詹姆斯·卡特仍然将这一事件记为他凯旋的时刻。
It's been a story that I've told to friends, you know, at parties or to new people I've met and someone said, hey, you need to hear James's story about how he got his stolen bike bag. And I was happy to tell that story because ultimately I felt that it was the best possible outcome at the end and everyone carried on with their lives. I told James that Donovan had contacted Hidden Brain in response to a callout for stories about being haunted by past events. I told him how Donovan's arrest led to his being fired from his job and how his graduate program had rescinded his offer of admission. I told him how Donovan had tried to find work after his conviction and how employer after employer turned him down because of his criminal record. James slowly absorbed what I told him. We were talking on Zoom and he looked increasingly distraught. Yeah, I've gone quite a long time thinking that that was handled in a certain way
这是一个我曾向朋友们讲过的故事，你知道，在派对上或向我遇到的新朋友讲，有人会说，嘿，你得听听詹姆斯的那个故事，他是怎么找回被偷的自行车。我很高兴讲这个故事，因为最终我觉得这是最好的结局，每个人都继续着他们的生活。我告诉詹姆斯，唐纳文联系了《隐藏的大脑》，回应了一次关于被过去的事件所困扰的故事征集。我告诉他唐纳文的被捕是如何导致他被解雇的，以及他的研究生项目是如何撤回对他的录取通知的。我告诉他唐纳文在定罪后是如何努力寻找工作，以及雇主一个接一个地因为他的犯罪记录而拒绝了他。詹姆斯慢慢地消化着我告诉他的话。我们在 Zoom 上交谈，他看起来越来越痛苦。是的，我有相当长的一段时间以为事情是按某种方式处理的，
and you were telling me it wasn't. Yeah. So correct. Yes, that is what I'm telling you. Well, that sucks. That really does. I mean, I think I'm hearing you clearly say is that was definitely not what you had intended. No. There's heartbreaking.
而你告诉我事实并非如此。是的。所以没错。是的，这就是我告诉你的。好吧，这太糟糕了。真的太糟糕了。我的意思是，我想我清楚地听到你说的，那绝对不是你的本意。没有。这太令人心碎了。
Had I known that would be the case, then I've gone all of this time thinking that there was what I felt probably the best possible outcome from this case. And now I'm finding out that one of the primary things that I wanted to make sure didn't happen was what has ultimately taken place over this time period. And it's gut-wrenching. and it's gut wrenching. I'm trying to describe what it is that I'm feeling right now. And it is a immense sadness that I've gone all this time thinking that he served a short period of time and was then able to
如果我知道会是这样，那我这么长时间以来一直以为我得到了这个案件中可能最好的结局。而现在我发现，我最想确保不发生的事情之一，最终在这个时间段里发生了。这让人揪心。这让人揪心。我正试图描述我现在的心情。这是一种巨大的悲伤，我这么长时间以来一直以为他服刑了一小段时间，然后就能够
carry on with his life. And my goal of then not being a knock on societal cost has not been met in any way, shape or form going forward. And I'm just hearing this for the first time after all his years. And now I don't feel like the penalty that he's received was appropriate for his actions. And that's a horrible feeling. I mean, are you experiencing guilt? I mean, because again, I don't think you did anything that was wrong. I mean, I don't think your actions can be questioned in any way. Well, now, I don't even know what my options would have been. What other approaches I could have taken. I feel guilty that my actions has led to that. But I'm wondering if you were in conversation with Donovan right now, what would you tell
继续他的生活了。而我当初希望不要对社会造成后续成本的目标，根本没有以任何方式、形状或形式实现。我多年来第一次听到这个消息。现在我觉得他受到的惩罚对他的行为来说并不合适。这是一种糟糕的感觉。我的意思是，你感到内疚吗？我的意思是，因为再次说明，我不认为你做了任何错误的事。我的意思是，我不认为你的行为可以受到任何性质的质疑。好吧，现在，我甚至不知道我当时还有什么选择。我还能采取什么其他方法。我为我的行为导致了这样的结果感到内疚。但我想知道如果你现在正在和唐纳文对话，你会对他说什么
him, James? Right now, I'd want to say I'm sorry. It's haunted him for all this time, which part of my brain is telling me that that's a really ridiculous response to have. But he would not have been haunted by this. And I can't help but feel that part of that is my responsibility. James Carter is not the only one who feels this way. At the end of legal proceedings, many victims feel that what they received was not what they needed. Some scholars have pointed to a different model of justice called restorative justice. The goal here isn't just to meet our punishment, it's to try and heal the moral wound caused
他，詹姆斯？现在，我想说对不起。这件事困扰了他这么长时间，我的理智告诉我，这是一种非常荒谬的反应。但他本不会因此而受到困扰。我不禁觉得部分责任在于我。詹姆斯·卡特并不是唯一一个有这种感觉的人。在法律程序结束时，许多受害者觉得他们得到的并不是他们真正需要的。一些学者指出了一种被称为恢复性司法的新模式。这里的目标不仅仅是给予惩罚，而是试图抚平
by an offense. It's a model where victims and perpetrators are not kept apart. They don't just interact through intermediaries, but meet face to face. Each party takes turns speaking about the crime and its consequences. Victims may help decide on the punishment for the person who harmed them.
由犯罪造成的道德创伤。在这种模式中，受害者和加害者不会被隔离。他们不仅仅通过中间人交流，而是进行面对面的会面。各方轮流讲述犯罪行为及其后果。受害者可以帮助决定对伤害他们的人的惩罚。
They often get answers and an apology. Offenders might receive reduced sentences. Many states have passed laws permitting the use of restorative justice in some criminal cases as a way to reduce incarceration and as a more effective way of dealing with the emotional harms of both crime and punishment. A few days after I interviewed James, I invited both James and Donovan to join me for a joint interview on Zoom. They agreed.
他们通常能得到答案和道歉。加害者可能会获得减刑。许多州已经通过法律，允许在某些刑事案件中使用恢复性司法，作为减少监禁的一种方式，以及更有效地处理犯罪和惩罚带来的情感创伤的方法。在我采访詹姆斯几天后，我邀请了詹姆斯和多诺万一起参加我在Zoom上的联合采访。他们同意了。
It was the first time they were seeing each other after their encounter outside the Starbucks. James went first. He told Donovan how his family was barely scraping by when Donald installed his bike. Certainly when that bicycle was stolen, I knew that there was no way that I could afford to replace it. And it was an integral part of not just getting around campus for meetings and that sort of thing, but also that it was a significant loss to our family, even though it's, you know, essentially just two wheels in a frame.
这是他们在星巴克外面相遇后第一次见面。詹姆斯先说。他告诉多诺万，当唐纳德（注：应为多诺万）安装他的自行车时，他的家庭是如何勉强维持生计的。当然，当那辆自行车被偷时，我知道我绝对买不起一辆新的来替换它。它不仅是我们在校园里开会等活动的代步工具，而且对我们家庭来说也是一个重大的损失，尽管它本质上你知道，只是两个轮子和一个车架。
It was far more than that. James also talked about how the theft shaped his larger feelings about his town. That was the first time that I had experienced crime in Harrisonburg. And that changed my perception of what I felt was a very, a very safe town. James, just hearing your story, it makes me feel almost even more sorrowful that you felt uncomfortable in Harrisonburg and that you even had a family, too. That's news to me and it's hard for me to hear that, you know, that bike meant so much to you emotionally and that I had memories. So I actually haven't even thought about
这远不止于此。詹姆斯还谈到了这起盗窃案是如何塑造他对所在小镇的看法的。那是我在哈Harrisonburg（哈里森堡）第一次经历犯罪。这改变了我对这个我一直觉得非常、非常安全的小镇的看法。詹姆斯，听到你的故事，我甚至更替你感到难过，因为你曾在哈里森堡感到不安，而且你当时居然还有一个家庭。这对我来说是个新闻，听到这些我很难受，你知道，那辆自行车对你在情感上有那么大的意义，而且我也有过回忆。所以实际上我甚至没有想过
if it was an important bike to someone because I did think it was abandoned. Donovan told James about his precarious financial situation when he stole the bike, how he was about to start grad school and would have to cut back on his work hours. He also told James what it felt like to pull off the crime.
这辆自行车对某人来说是否重要，因为我真的以为它是被遗弃的。多诺万向詹姆斯讲述了他在偷车时 precarious（不稳定）的财务状况，他是如何即将开始读研究生，并不得不减少工作时间的。他还告诉詹姆斯实施犯罪时的感受。
So after I'd taken the bike, I still felt guilty I remember the whole time, even like even going to the Starbucks to meet you. I remember thinking, oh my goodness, this is gonna solve this problem really quickly, but also like, this feels awful at the same time. I think I remember feeling feeling pretty bad.
所以在拿了自行车之后，我仍然感到内疚，我记得整个过程，甚至包括去星巴克见你的那一刻。我记得当时在想，哦天哪，这能很快解决这个问题，但同时也觉得，这感觉太糟糕了。我想我记得当时感觉非常糟糕。
Donovan told James how quickly his life unraveled after his arrest. You know, it was incredibly embarrassing that my mug shot was circulated around my co-workers that I really got along really well with and I was very involved in the community So then I felt like oh my goodness my face has been seen everywhere I need to get out of this town even though I had just bought a house So I was I was in a very very very dark place very dark place I mean as dark as it gets feeling like there was no feature for myself I'm wondering James if you might be able to tell Donovan what your reaction is to his account
多诺万告诉詹姆斯，在他被捕后，他的生活是如何迅速崩溃的。你知道，我的大头照在我和那些相处得非常好、在社区里非常活跃的同事们之间传阅，这太尴尬了。所以当时我觉得，天哪，我的脸到处都被看到了，我需要离开这个小镇，尽管我刚买了一座房子。所以我当时处于一个非常、非常黑暗的地方，非常黑暗的地方，可以说是最黑暗的处境，觉得自己的未来毫无希望。我想知道，詹姆斯，你能不能告诉多诺万，你对他的这些遭遇有什么反应？
of what happened to him after the arrest. How is that sitting with you right now? What are you hearing? What are your feelings towards Donovan? I felt a tremendous amount of sorrow and regret. I've been trying to process this and understand that actually my actions and the decisions I made to pursue charges have had some very real and very unexpected long-term impacts on yourself that have ultimately gone completely the opposite way
对于他被捕后发生的事情？你现在对此有什么看法？你听到了什么？你对多诺万有什么感觉？我感到了极大的悲伤和遗憾。我一直在试图理清并理解，实际上，我的行动以及我决定追究责任的决定，对你产生了一些非常真实且非常意料之外的长期影响，这些影响最终完全违背了
of every intention that I had. So as I now think back to it, should I have dropped the charges? Should I have, you know, all of this time, Donovan and I have, you know, have had no interaction whatsoever and have drawn our own conclusions about who that person is and why they did those things. But to hear the decisions that I made after getting that bike back had such a detrimental impact on someone was deeply troubling to me.
我最初的每一个意图。所以现在回想起来，我当时应该撤销指控吗？我应该……你知道，这么长时间以来，我和多诺万没有任何互动，我们只是各自对对方是谁以及他们为什么这样做作出了自己的结论。但是听到我拿回自行车后做出的决定竟然对某人产生了如此巨大的负面影响，这让我感到深深的不安。
It's painful for me to hear that. And you know, listen to how you approached going about this case with the prosecutor. That is not at all the story that I heard on my side. I heard almost actually quite the opposite. I heard from my lawyer that this guy, it sounds like he would like a pretty high sentence for you. The thing that I think makes me sad is that I feel like It sounds like he would like a pretty high sentence for you. The thing that I think makes me sad is that I feel like the conversation we are having
听到这些让我感到痛苦。你知道，听听你是如何与检察官接洽这个案件的。这和我这边听到的故事完全不同。我听到的几乎可以说是完全相反的。我从我的律师那里听说，这家伙，听起来他想给你判很重的刑。让我感到难过的是，我觉得……听起来他想给你判很重的刑。让我感到难过的是，我觉得我们现在正在进行的谈话
now should have been a conversation that the two of you had nine years ago. And it seems sad to me that that conversation didn't happen. Absolutely. And also it's unfortunate because if you and I had gotten a chance to make amends, I would have even wanted to give you the bikes back in a more repaired state than you had actually had them. And then also, I would have probably wanted to pay you as some type of payment of sorry. I would have felt incredibly sorrowful to you. And it's something that I
本应该是你们九年前就该进行的谈话。在我看来，那次对话没有发生让人觉得很遗憾。绝对是这样。而且也很不幸，如果你我当时有机会弥补，我甚至会想把自行车修得比你原本的状况还要好，然后还交还给你。另外，我可能还会想赔偿你一些钱作为道歉。我会对你感到无比的心痛。而这是我
had never even thought of before because I was told from my lawyer that you were quite the different character than what is being described to me in this interview. I'm wondering, Donovan, you know, if that opportunity had presented itself nine years ago, and in fact, there'd basically been some kind of forum where James could have been assured that his safety and the safety of his family was not in jeopardy. And you could have been assured that this was a forum in which you were not necessarily going to be, you know, tard and feathered, but it was basically a chance for the two of you to talk.
以前从未想过的事情，因为我的律师告诉我，你是一个和这次采访中描述的截然不同的人。多诺万，我想知道，如果九年前出现过那种机会，事实上，如果有一种论坛，能够向詹姆斯保证他的安全和家人的安全不会受到威胁，并且能向你保证，这不是一个你会遭到“羽毛沾身”式羞辱的场所，而基本上只是你们两人交谈的一个机会。
In some ways, what I'm suggesting is actually not a radical idea, because of course, in interpersonal settings, certainly if you have kids, this happens all the time. Someone does something wrong to your kid, your kid does something wrong to somebody else, and what do we do? We don't basically separate the two parties so that they don't talk to each other
从某种程度上说，我所建议的其实并不是一个激进的想法，因为在人际交往中，当然，如果你有孩子，这种事经常发生。有人对你的孩子做错了事，你的孩子对别人做错了事，我们怎么做？我们通常不会把这两方分开，让他们在接下来的八年里
for the next eight years. We actually get them together in a room and basically say, let's talk about what happened and let's each party basically express sort of what happened to them and have some some sense of closure. And I'm wondering if that opportunity had been provided to you, Donovan, at the time, what would you have said to James? Yeah, James, I would have said, I'm very sorry for, this was my situation and I have a lot of stress going on. And it was an impulsive decision that I felt nervous and anxious about even during the decision. And it was a one-off decision. I mean, I have nothing on my record before this and this is
互不交流。我们实际上是把他们聚在一个房间里，然后基本上说，让我们谈谈发生了什么，让各方都表达一下他们各自的遭遇，从而获得某种程度的了结。我想知道，如果在当时给予你这样的机会，多诺万，你会对詹姆斯说些什么？是的，詹姆斯，我会说，我非常抱歉，这是我的情况，我当时承受着巨大的压力。那是一个冲动的决定，甚至在做决定时我都感到紧张和焦虑。那是一次性的决定。我的记录上以前没有任何污点，而这正是我
what I was planning on doing with the money. It was just a means to an end, essentially. And I'm very, very sorry for this impact that I have on you immediately. I didn't realize that it was one of your only forms of transportation. And I didn't realize that you had a family. In my mind, you were just a man who had a bicycle. I didn't, that maybe potentially worked at JMU. That was the only idea in my head of who you were. You know, I would immediately want to make things right.
当时打算用钱做的事。它本质上只是达到目的的手段。对于我当时对你造成的直接影响，我感到非常非常抱歉。我没有意识到那是你仅有的交通工具之一。我也没有意识到你还有个家庭。在我的脑海里，你只是一个有一辆自行车的人。我当时并没有……或许他在JMU工作？这就是我脑海中关于你是谁的全部概念。你知道，我会立刻想要纠正错误。
I would have wanted to make things right immediately. You know, because I did, I'm the one who did something wrong. I don't remember if you recalled on of them, but you emailed one of the accounts that I set up that evening to apologise. And you mentioned that you were trying to save up for a house, and that was the reason that you stole my bike. And at the time, I myself was struggling financially. And so it was kind of hurtful to receive that message to say that hey, I took something of yours because I wanted something and That made an impression on me as to the type of person that you are and that's what I formed
我本想立刻把事情纠正过来。你知道，因为我，是我做错了事。多诺万，我不记得你是否还记得，那天晚上你给我设置的其中一个账号发了一封邮件道歉。你提到你当时正在努力存钱买房，这就是你偷我自行车的原因。当时我自己也在经济上苦苦挣扎。所以收到那条说“嘿，我拿了你的东西因为我想要某样东西”的信息时，确实有点伤人。这给我留下了深刻的印象，让我觉得你是一个什么样的人，这就是我所形成的
my understanding of who Donovan is and To go through the last nine years of my life, believing that that was the case, only to hear the decisions that I made have had such a negative impact on you, was deeply troubling for me. And I've spoken to countless different friends over the last few days and they all had different approaches to it somewhere. Well, that guy had everything coming to him too. That's really sad that you wanted this to be a case of someone having a fresh start, but that's not what's happened. So I've had the opportunity to talk it through to people and It's very interesting how people's opinions vary based upon their background. And I'm James.
对多诺万是谁的理解。在过去的九年里，我一直带着这种信念生活，直到今天才听到我所做的决定对你产生了如此负面的影响，这让我感到深深的不安。过去几天里，我和无数不同的朋友聊过，他们都有不同的看法。有人会说，那家伙也是咎由自取。真遗憾，你本来希望这是一起能给某人一个重新开始机会的案件，但事实并非如此。所以我有机会和人们讨论这件事，并且发现根据不同的背景，人们的意见有多么不同。我是詹姆斯。
I'm wondering if this forum had presented itself nine years ago, and you had heard Donovan basically say to you what he just said, how do you think you might have responded? I think, I think I would have certainly have liked to have relayed to Donovan the meaning that that bicycle had to me, that while it wasn't just a asset, it was also the memories had been formed with it that you could never get back with a new bicycle. So, yes, there was a financial side to it, but also there were a lot of experiences that were tied in with that bicycle.
我想知道，如果九年前出现过这样的机会，当你听到多诺万对你说了他刚刚说的那番话时，你觉得你会有什么反应？我想，我想我肯定会很想向多诺万传达那辆自行车对我的意义，它不仅仅是一笔资产，它还承载着那些随着一辆新自行车永远无法找回的回忆。所以，是的，这里面有经济层面的一面，但也有很多与那辆自行车紧密相连的经历。
The there was no way of getting those back. And so I think that was part of the driving force was the, yes, okay, I definitely can't afford to buy a new bike to replace it but also this is my family's bike. So I think I would have certainly wanted you to have understood the implications that it wasn't just purely a financial thing but also there was a financial thing, but also there was a deeply emotional side to losing that. And so that while it is a in the grand scheme of things, you know, a minor crime, when you experience it yourself personally, that does alter your perception of things. In previous centuries, when people clashed, they settled scores with their fists or with vigilante justice.
那些是无法找回的。所以我想这也是驱动力的一部分，是的，好吧，我确实买不起一辆新自行车来替代它，但这也是我们全家的自行车。所以我想我肯定会希望你能理解其中的含义——它不仅仅纯粹是金钱的问题，虽然金钱也是一方面，但失去它其实有着极深的情感层面。因此，尽管从宏观角度来看，这是一起轻微的罪行，但当你亲身经历时，它确实会改变你对事情的看法。在过去的几个世纪里，当人们发生冲突时，他们会用拳头或私刑来解决恩怨。
A great accomplishment of our modern legal system is that it limits cycles of violence. Bloody feuds that last generations are now a thing of the past. But in return for turning human disputes into orderly proceedings, courts sometimes sacrifice the emotional dimensions of crime and punishment. People who are wronged don't just want perpetrators to be punished. Many want an acknowledgement of the harms done to them. They want offenders to truly understand the harm they have caused. They want apologies that are heartfelt, not coerced.
我们现代法律体系的一大成就就是它限制了暴力循环。持续数代的血腥世仇现在已成为过去式。但作为将人类纠纷转化为有序程序的回报，法庭有时会牺牲犯罪和惩罚的情感维度。受到伤害的人不仅希望加害者受到惩罚。许多人希望对方承认对他们造成的伤害。他们希望加害者真正理解他们所造成的伤害。他们希望得到发自内心而非被迫的道歉。
When victims and perpetrators get to see one another as three-dimensional human beings. Instead of caricatures, it becomes easier for everyone to move on with their lives. Isn't that what justice is supposed to do? Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor. Working on this episode made us realize there is another psychological dimension to the story, which we might explore in a new episode.
当受害者和加害者开始将彼此视为有血有肉、立体的人，而不是刻板印象时，每个人更容易继续他们的生活。这难道不是正义应该做的事吗？《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括 Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes 和 Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle 是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。制作这期节目让我们意识到，这个故事还有另一个心理维度，我们可能会在新的节目中探讨它。
Can you remember a time when you hurt someone, perhaps side-swiped another car and left without leaving a note, or took something important from another person, but were never caught or punished? Perhaps the guilt about what you did has stayed with you for many years. or took something important from another person, but were never caught or punished? Perhaps the guilt about what you did has stayed with you for many years. If you have a personal story like that, and are willing to share it with a hidden brain audience, please record a short voice memo on your phone, telling us what happened,
你能记起曾经伤害过某人的时刻吗，比如擦撞了别人的车却没有留下字条，或者从另一个人那里拿走了重要的东西，却从未被抓到或受到惩罚？也许你对所做之事的内疚感已经伴随了你多年。或者从另一个人那里拿走了重要的东西，却从未被抓到或受到惩罚？也许你对所做之事的内疚感已经伴随了你多年。如果你有这样一段个人经历，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享，请在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录，告诉我们发生了什么，
and what you wish you could say to the person you hurt, and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, guilty. Arun Sanghiro this week is listener and hiddenbrain supporter, Laurie Hackney. Laurie lives in Oregon and likes to listen to hiddenbrain while taking her morning walk. She writes, My all-time favorite episode of the podcast was Laughter, The Best Medicine.
以及你希望对你伤害过的人说些什么，然后将其发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。主题行请写：guilty。本周的赞助商是听众兼《隐藏的大脑》支持者 Laurie Hackney。Laurie 住在俄勒冈州，喜欢在早晨散步时收听《隐藏的大脑》。她写道：我最喜欢的播客节目一直是《笑声，最好的良药》。
While my brain learned something new from every episode I listened to, the laughter episode had me laughing throughout while learning something new about the benefits of laughter. It was a hoot to listen to. Thanks so much for sharing that, Laurie, and thanks as well for your support of the show. We truly appreciate it. If you enjoyed this episode, if stories like this make you think and reflect on your own life, please help us build more episodes like this. Join Laurie and support our work.
虽然我在听的每一期节目中都能学到新东西，但笑声那一期让我从头笑到尾，同时还学到了关于笑声益处的新知识。听起来真是太棒了。非常感谢你分享这些，Laurie，也感谢你对节目的支持。我们真心感激。如果你喜欢这期节目，如果这样的故事能让你思考并反思自己的生活，请帮助我们制作更多这样的节目。加入 Laurie 的行列，支持我们的工作。
You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. That side again is support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。网址再重复一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。